speech
oh my god
i can't believe this
what the hell
hi
wow like i am in shock
i wrote something because i'm not
eloquent and i'm drunk
but um
the day that i won this award or i'm
sorry the day that i got nominated for
this award my grandmother passed away
mary lucille
and she would always say i don't go back
i'm here
so let's be here right now
and i'm here and this is crazy
so thank you so much
thank you so much for this and thank you
grandma
um whoa what a journey this life is
um
just taking a breath because this is
crazy
um
thank you brilliant janixa bravo your
genius mine
your soul
[Applause]
thank you for having me be your zola
thank you so much for everything for
every detail for just thank you for who
you are
thank you to my wonderful cast brilliant
coleman
nicholas braun riley keough my best
friend
t.s madison
i i'm nervous that i'm gonna forget
people but i'm trying my best here
um
uh thank you zola
for knowing that your story was worth
telling and only the way that you could
tell it
was gold thank you for just being you
and your power and and also helping me
find my own
um
i really really love the words
independent film and spirit
um all of this world the world that we
live in but also just like being an
artist being a human is really weird
and um you can feel like you're alone
and on this island and like being
rejected but the boundlessness of this
the spirit of this
is what keeps me uplifted in my attempt
so
i just hope to keep attempting and i
thank all of you for how hard it's so
hard to make movies thank you katie
byron at our table the production
designer
and sherry r.a.d and
jeremy o'haras just all the people that
see me and inspire me all of you like
it's hard to do what we do it's hard to
be a human like it's really weird it's
like the most impossible circumstances
and we're all just trying so thank you
for being live thank you for this
you